But he is so [__] up that she has so much Botox in
her face that I cannot picture her crying. I actually can't picture
her showing any emotion at all. The rumor that gets circulated
is that Jordan Peterson's been dead for like a year and a half
now. Oh, no. Okay. There's only so many times I can be like,
yeah, they must have put garlic in that food cuz you're really
bloated right now when you look the exact same. There's only
so many times I can have that conversation, okay?
Okay. All right. Where are we going next? We going to do the
JBP thing? We want to watch JBP talk about or sorry, Michaela
Peterson, talk about how her dad is still sick.
I don't think we've missed one of these. I think we've gotten
all of them.
This is a video >> this works cuz we can watch Michaela
for a little bit and she will tell us what's going on with JBP,
okay? Hey guys. This is a video update on dad's health and I
would have updated you guys sooner but he's still been really
sick and he got worse over the last few months and I'm 25 weeks
pregnant and I wasn't able to record anything without weeping
the whole time until this week apparently. Uh and it stresses
out my whole family to talk about it online and there's no point
in adding stress to an already stressful situation except that
because we're public, dad in particular, it's also stressful
not talking about it because then rumors get started and then
that's all people wonder about. So, here goes.
Dad's been suffering from an old neurological injury that's more
recently been causing akathisia. Akathisia is the worst thing
I've ever seen anyone go through. That sounds dramatic but it's
true. We talked about it in 2020 and 2021 when he experienced
it after clonazepam injured him. And I'll explain why it's an
injury in a bit. I had a very brief experience with akathisia
with symptoms that were extremely horrifying but not as severe
as his when I went through antidepressant withdrawal from Lexapro.
That was just over 10 years ago and that experience, like the
withdrawal period that was really severe, lasted 2 and 1/2 years
for me where I was nearly disabled. This was kind of before I
had a public
thing going on. Uh that's when I just had a blog. I've linked
a bunch of papers below about everything I'm going to talk about
so that people watching can get scientific background information
about what this is because it's not talked about nearly enough
for how catastrophic it is. In my opinion, psych med injuries
and psych meds as a whole should be considered a national emergency
given one in six Americans or possibly more dependent on the
stat is on one of these medications and long-term use appears
to cause mitochondrial dysfunction that manifests as a neurological
injury.
I'll get into more of that in in a bit, too. Akathisia is a side
effect that's way more common than people know.
Dude, I do I have to look this up? Why is she She's got to define
it, right? >> medications. Although other medications can
sometimes cause it and so can sudden cessation from those medications.
That's a huge trigger. So, like suddenly stopping one of the
medications that can also cause it. And sometimes people with
Parkinson's can experience it, too. It is intolerable discomfort
that makes people want to crawl out of their skin. It's a neurological
injury, really. A lot of people don't survive it and there's
no quick fix. Although I'll go into how we've dealt with it before.
Uh without videotaping me sobbing and it seems like a bunch of
my sadness this week has turned into anger. Okay, akathisia is
a movement disorder characterized by an intense uncontrollable
need to move often caused by antipsychotic or antidepressant
medications. Symptoms include severe inner restlessness, pacing,
marching in place, shifting weight. I'm not I'm not laughing
cuz it's funny. I'm I'm like kind of laughing a little bit as
in I
feel like I have this where I need to move a lot um basically
anytime I'm standing still, I'll start like tapping or I'll I'll
just do anything to have like some part of my body moving at
any given point in time. I'll like be tapping something, I'll
be fiddling with something. So, it just feels like I have some
It it it's nothing like this. I'm sure this is horrifying for
people who suffer from it but for me, I'm just like
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So sorry. I I already Ramond is I already was
like, hey, I know it's I don't have that. I'm saying when I read
the initial symptoms, I'm like, oh, I feel like a little bit
in that way. >> which I is actually at least more endurable
for me but uh without posting a video of me sobbing, I don't
know how to describe how bad it is in words but I'm going to
take a stab at it. You guys should look up videos of other people
suffering with it if you want to. It's catastrophic. Before I
get into it, let me be super clear. Dad has not been on a psych
medication since January 2020. This recent flare-up of neurological
symptoms wasn't due to new medications. That's partly why we
had no idea what was going on for about 6 months. We went to
specialists, obviously, and it was misdiagnosed repeatedly which
is super common. Um Danny got pneumonia and sepsis and obviously
that's a whole thing to recover from, too, and
dangerous, you know. This year's just
terrible. This recent flare-up that started last August was likely
due to the stress of both of his parents, my grandparents, dying
last year, moving countries, selling his home, and mold exposures
which was enough to trigger a recurrence of neurological symptoms
like what he experienced in 2020, 2021, something we obviously
didn't think was possible after 5 and 1/2 years away from the
psych
It was a timing. Dude, I The unfortunate thing about these videos
is like
I I don't know how to explain it without sounding like awful,
okay? I sound like horrible cuz she's describing something
But he is so [__] up that she has so much Botox in
her face that I cannot picture her crying. I actually can't picture
her showing any emotion at all. I don't know if she can picture
herself showing any emotion at all. Her face is like permanently
paralyzed in place like this. medications but I've talked to
you psychiatrists who say they have patients that experience
what experience this. This has been unbelievably hard on my family.
Every day for the last year has been hell. I haven't been posting
podcasts regularly online because until a few days ago, I've
cried every single day. My brother is stressed out, my mom is
stressed. I mean, it's impacting so many Um and of course, my
dad, you know. Uh mom's thank goodness such a strong person and
thank God for faith. If it weren't for my dad and our love for
him and the strength of our family and how we've been through
so many health problems, you almost adapt. No, you don't cuz
it's too awful but like we have got good communication skills
and we're closer if anything now. Otherwise, this would have
just crushed us. I've certainly been walking around in a state
of panic for almost a year now. Uh to make pregnancy hormones
definitely don't help that.
The weird thing to me or I don't know if I'd describe it as weird
I do understand that these symptoms would be terrible. I can
understand a lot of this stuff but I don't know I I can't imagine
and maybe it's just my lack of imagination or experience
something that would cause this or you'd have these symptoms
and you'd never have any period of like down time or reprieve
that you could like do a public message cuz basically when she
talks about rumors getting circulated online
the rumor that gets circulated is that Jordan Peterson's been
dead for like a year and a half now. That he basically hasn't
been seen publicly, that she's been running all his social media
and he's either like
totally out of his mind, like gone, or in a coma or passed away.
You know what I'm saying? Like that's those are the rumors. We
haven't seen Jordan Peterson in a long time. He hasn't made a
public appearance in a long time. No, I do not think there's
been pictures of him, either. Like I think there's basically
been nothing. But maybe maybe I'm just unaware, maybe I haven't
been following but I've not seen a picture. Like nobody's really
said
anything about like nobody's shown a picture of her or of him,
sorry.
So, I yeah, I have no idea where I Man, like what what illness
is like that?
Yeah, I'm guessing after if he did have an infection like pneumonia
and get sepsis, then he's probably like fairly emaciated, right?
I've heard a fortune that he's been cryogenically frozen. Well,
And then to make matters worse, I don't even want to mention
this really cuz I don't want to give it any attention but some
journalists online reached out to me trying to blame dad's symptoms
on stem cell treatments which is so dumb, it's hard to fathom.
Um and I responded which was stupid. You just should just never
respond to a journalist but I was like, hey, I really appreciate
you looking into doctors but like that's not what's going on
with dad. I'm going to talk about what's going on with dad. Um
but it just isn't associated with stem cells and he ignored
Anyway, that kind of thing is
annoying, obviously. So, dad had stem cell IVs over the years
a couple times uh to see if they can help with neurological pins
and needles and pain and like sensitivities and things. And I
had mentioned in one of my videos that last summer in June, he
had a stem cell IV from a specialist. This is a specialist I
don't know. It he was like hooked up with him from one of his
friends, a great specialist but it's not someone I'm connected
to. He stayed in a moldy hotel for that treatment and that brought
back symptoms. It wasn't the stem cell IV. He's had hordes of
those and trying to link
According to the The Times of India, he has akathisia. Well,
she just said he had akathisia, yeah. But it's good to know.
I'm guessing they sourced Michaela for that but the stem cell
IV in June to sepsis and trying to draw back symptoms. It wasn't
the stem cell IV. He's had hordes of those and trying to link
the stem cell IV in June to sepsis from pneumonia in October
is
Anyway, sep- sepsis happens within days of an infection. So,
not only are we dealing with missing my dad, pregnancy for me,
taking care of him,
and being really sad. Um the weird thing is, Marco Fley,
like I do think that they're in a unique position to [__]
up what's wrong with
quite explicitly, they have like a really weird history with
autoimmune diseases. Like I think Michaela was supposed to have
had some kind of arthritis when she was a kid that was crippling
and then the all meat diet is what what supposed to have fixed
it, right? Although now she's saying it was akathisia or something.
I don't even know. So, like I do I do feel like you're not really
getting truthful information. I'm not sure they're capable of
even providing truthful information. Like the family just seems
to have really weird opinions on doctors and medicine and so
I don't know that you would ever get like truthful information
on what's really going on there. But we also have to deal with
morons on the internet.
So, that sucks. The problem this year likely was that because
we didn't know stress and mold exposure uh stress, really, too,
could retrigger old neurological injuries, it was misdiagnosed
a bunch and then medications and supplements that were used by
a few of the doctors in hospitals worsened symptoms
enough that it got to the point where we were like, oh, we know
what akathisia is. Oh, no.
So, now that we know what it is and have proper doctors, it can
it can be carefully healed again like it has
Yeah, mold exposure, apparently. And it is. You can see So, thank
God for that. It's just horrifying and it's so
infuriating that these sensitivities, this damage that can cause
severe symptoms like this can last for so long after stopping
psych meds and then apparently be retriggered. Like to be
I would be very shocked if there's not a close friend of the
Petersons who's doing like a wellness check at some point. Like
if there hasn't already been Like I would be concerned that depending
on who's dictating his medical treatment
I I feel like I feel like we're going to hear some horror story
like a Steve Jobs esque horror story about Jordan
Like you know what I'm saying? I I do think that's the direction
this is headed is you're going to hear about how he had some
totally curable illness that doctors diagnosed and his family
was like no it's not that and we're not going to let you treat
anything for
Yeah, I just I it feels
Unfortunately, I understand Michaela. I'm not even going to I'm
not trying to mock her like I understand she's in pain cuz her
dad's sick. Okay.
Assuming we're not just getting lied to and I I don't assume
that.
I I don't trust these people with anything medical. I think they've
already had an incredibly questionable history in terms of how
they've talked about doctors and medicine and diets and all this
in the past. And I I feel like they're doing some natural that's
going to be him passing away at a young Well, I mean before his
time I guess. People online, this is another thing I'm frustrated
about. If I come off as like frustrated in this um I apologize.
I like I said I probably tried to channel them Oh, no. Okay.
I was like I can do this without crying. I probably tried to
chan DUDE DUDE DUDE, I HAD NO IDEA what I thought she was like
trying to look something up or do a joke. I'm not even making
it up. I'm not even making it up. I had no idea she was about
to cry.
>> There's no indication at all on her face. psych meds
and then apparently be
People online, this is another thing I'm frustrated about. If
I come off as like frustrated in this um I apologize. I like
I said I probably tried to channel them Oh, no. Okay. Dude, I
swear to God when she says oh no
I swear to God I have no It's like she farted or something. Like
that's the expression I got there. I swear. I Dude, I This is
like so foul to do when she's like delivering this information
about her family.
People online, this is another thing I'm frustrated about. If
I come off as like frustrated in this
I It's actually just crazy. I was like I can do this without
crying. I probably tried to channel It's the like and I dude
I probably this is probably really inappropriate, but Jesus it's
the Botox it's the surgery. Like it's the plastic surgery. She
just doesn't have facial
Wow, well I'm not feeling very well right now. But I've been
trying to channel my exasperation No, she is crying. I don't
think she's fake crying. I think she is crying. But I'm saying
that it's like it's the surgery is just taking me out of it entirely.
into anger
because I'm tired of being sad.
But this like neurological injury calling it an
is so stupid.
Dad doesn't fall into that category. We've made that clear so
many times. He quit smoking and drinking when he was 27. He just
isn't that. Instead, he falls into the unfortunately common category
of people who were prescribed psych meds long term. And it's
not like they were prescribed for no reason.
Um like severe crippling life ruining depression, the kind where
you can't get off the couch for 30 years. Runs in my family.
>> Yeah, I
Also, just to be clear
Is that water or is that like a cooler
I don't know what that brand is.
But that that bottle is not just
>> She uh uh what is that?
Mineral Oh, it's mineral water or something. It's like water.
I was like dude, that is not a good plan to start You've already
been drinking a little bit to do this to get your courage up
and then you drink more during the video. That would be crazy.
Addiction is not the problem.
Dude, what?
>> And it's not the kind of depression you can normally
diet and exercise away. Like people like to say that. They like
to look at depressed people and go why don't you eat better and
exercise more and it's like I'm in hell. Like you think that's
going to help? Although obviously that was before we knew about
only eating meat which did help. Um but in a really complicated
way. Like people didn't Who's going to guess that?
>> So it wasn't something you could
get rid of from cutting processed foods for instance. Myself,
my dad, my grandpa, my great grandpa had it. My great great grandpa
was left on a doorstep so I can't imagine he came from a very
stable family.
Uh okay. I have a Kleenex now. Um so where was I? >> Good
to know. Good to know. Yeah, depression. So when when dad started
to be badly impacted by depression in the '90s and he had it
he said he had it since he was a kid. Um he was impacted enough
that he was having a hard Baby Poison and Marty Epstein
There's there seems to be a to direct correlation between how
much you've donated to this channel and how likely you are to
just blame benzos for this, okay?
Cuz you guys are going crazy.
>> Just repeat Bro, this is just the benzos. He's just
burned out guys. He's fine. He's walk it off, buddy. He's just
burned out. >> lecturing he took an SSRI. We were told
it was a genetic serotonin problem and antidepressants were basically
a vitamin for a serotonin deficiency, which is still what people
are told. Even though that has been completely
And when I started having symptoms when I was a kid of OCD, suicidal
thoughts, extreme anxiety, anger, uh my psychiatrist just who
was assigned to kids with autoimmune disorders like so many people
with autoimmune disorders are on psych meds put me on Celexa
at the time and that was eventually changed to Lexapro. And they
helped a lot initially. I thought they saved my life for years
like a life from hellish depression. And so did dad. One out
of five or six like I said people in the US he's on a psychiatric
medication. They're not addicts. They don't even know these medications
are dependence forming because their doctors say they're not.
And the dangers surrounding these medications certainly aren't
well known even now. That's a large part of the reason for this
video. I was like I don't want to talk about it really, but it's
hap
I need to go do a video. Listen.
My dad's sick. I don't know what to do.
I need to go do a video warn people that medication prescribed
by their doctor is not healthy for them. And it's so bad that
people need to know because
it's not rare. And dependence forming to clarify that it's different
than what people think of when they think of addiction. It means
your brain changes to adapt to the
So if you pull it out especially quickly, your brain can't handle
it. It's not that you want to take it or enjoy taking it. It
could be causing severe side effects. This is what happened with
dad. He started getting akathisia on Klonopin, but pulling it
out is is impossible and it worsens it. It it's a terrible situation.
Um but this was 6 years ago, you know.
Anyway, apparently that differentiation between being on a psych
med and being an addict is too complicated for most people or
at least for the people complaining on the internet. But I That's
not Hold on. That's not you saying that he's on Klonopin again,
is it? There's no way That sounded almost like you're saying
that he is back on Klonopin or that he never got off of Klonopin
Klonopin even though you went to Russia to do like a emergency
detox
on him before. I
Am I crazy? That's the implication there, right? Klonopin is
a benzo, is it not? Yeah, Klonopin is a benzo. She said 6 years
ago she said they couldn't pull him off of it, but it sounds
like hey we couldn't just pull him off of it. Like he needs it.
And now it's like well, the difference between drug addiction
and this is I I'm sorry. I I'm hearing that like there's some
soft defense of the idea that he might be on benzos. Excuse me,
that he might be on benzos
And that and that he needs them to make sure it doesn't get worse.
severe side effects. This is what happened with dad. He started
getting akathisia on Klonopin, but pulling it out is is impossible
and it worsens it. It it's a terrible situation. Um but this
was 6 years ago, you know.
Anyway, apparently that differentiation between being on a psych
med and being an addict is too complicated for most Okay, so
the treatment for akathisia is benzos and beta blockers.
Okay, so if the treatment is benzos and
Then but then was it not an addiction or
Cuz I thought I thought they were quite open about the fact that
he'd struggle with addiction issues and that's why he went to
go get a detox. Like he got put in a coma for a detox. No?
That was my impression of the treatment he went under when he
went to Russia was that he needed to go to Russia to get put
in a coma and get detoxed.
people or at least for the people complaining on the internet.
But I thought I it should be addressed anyway. And I'm someone
who honestly looks at classic addicts say heroin and thinks they
must be suffering and it's a complicated issue and I feel bad
for them and there's more to it in my opinion than someone who
just took drugs and is an addict. I think there's likely physiological
issues at play for classic addicts. But dad's not in that category.
Uh so now I guess I can talk about what akathisia felt like to
me and when dad recovers he can talk about his experience if
he wants to. For me and I don't want to like get into details
more than that really cuz it's too hard on my
And it's I don't want to. Um so my experience with akathisia
for me it it hit for the first time 2 weeks after I stopped Lexapro
in 2015.
After going on a ketogenic diet that I kind of randomly went
on when I went on an elimination diet that just happened to be
ketogenic. I cut out almost everything like meat and vegetables.
And that put my depression into remission. My depression went
away. I could feel it go away one day about 3 months into the
diet and I thought I'm never going to take another pill again.
And I stopped everything. Uh that depre Oh, that's
I mean
Dude, I feel like
Is that
Is that not essentially
the idea that you just lost weight and you didn't feel depressed
cuz you were depressed cuz you were overweight and you like are
solving one of your problems and it's leading you to feel better
and feel brighter cuz you feel more attractive
Is that not like an explanation that wouldn't get you off of
your meds
I feel like I lost a bunch of weight and then I felt better so
I stopped taking my meds. I don't know if that's good. depression
even on the Lexapro was so debilitating that when I started doing
dietary intervention testing it out and removing things, I focused
on my arthritis which was crippling. I had joints replaced from
it because I thought that was the easier thing to fix and that
there was no way dietary intervention was going to touch something
as severe as that depression that runs in my family. That's how
you know the Lexapro wasn't fixing the depression because I felt
the depression go away on the ketogenic paleo diet I was on kind
of like meat and vegetables and a bit of fruit while on Lexapro.
So I stopped Lexapro over a 2-week period which is basically
cold turkey which was crazy after taking it for 11 years. But
this was 2015 and even now doctors will wean people down in 2
to 4 weeks. If you have a doctor that suggests Bro, I take I
take some form of stimulant, okay?
And I have since I like for a long time for like more than a
decade.
I can stop taking that and I get like 2 days of like a down
and then I'm fine.
It's like it's because I feel like, you know, lethargic randomly
throughout the
But it's like it's not anywhere near like if I'm doing anything
entertaining. It's like lethargy lethargy if I'm like doing something
boring. If I'm like studying or doing something like that.
Different with stimulants? Okay. I'm just I'm just sitting here
and saying like I dude, I have nothing like this. I have nothing
close to this. It's like I get like a day or two of like a kind
of have a headache and it sucks and then it's like totally fine.
Um it's not actually an amphetamine that I take but it's it's
essentially something like
Yeah, it is like not super important. But I think I could probably
stream without it to be honest with you.
I Okay, stimulants are just not as hard. Okay, maybe I I was
thinking of it as like a psych drug but maybe not.
But I've also taken it for a very long
As you wean down off of a long-term psych med in 2 to 4 weeks
run.
That can literally give people neurological injury and that's
what happened to my family from pulling the medication out too
fast. Although we were getting injured on the medication too.
Uh people need to hyperbolic taper and I have links below to
it which is roughly a 10% reduction over every new dose. So if
you go from 20 mg to 18 mg then the next reduction is smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller. Um and sometimes that takes
years and sometimes people still like can't do it. So I developed
insane sensitivities to food, light, sound, stress, smells, chemicals,
vitamins, supplements like my body freaked out. This is why I
eventually started only eating meat. That wasn't for fun. It
was because I was insane.
And getting to the meat diet took me 2 years to figure out and
I suffered quite a bit even on the paleo and ketogenic diet during
that 2-year 2 and 1/2 year So the akathisia and the bad psych
med injury symptoms felt like I was overwhelmed with a sense
of impending doom that was stronger than anything you can naturally
feel. And I know that because for instance last summer I was
in the hospital with my newborn
and we thought she was going to die. And that was the worst thing
I've ever experienced. Um but the stress response I experienced
during antidepressant withdrawal was almost hallucinogenic. Like
it wasn't a natural stress response. That's I guess the best
way I can describe it. Uh it felt like I was falling into a volcano
while being chased by a bear. Like I had the physical sensation
sometimes that I was falling. And there were days when the only
thing that felt soothing was wrapping my arms around me. This
was like more of the akathisia symptoms and rocking back and
forth.
Unfortunately, dude, it I feel bad if this is like legitimately
all of these things are actually happening to them and it is
like exactly she lays out. But I Wait, what did she say? She
said the
Wait, is there some line in this that's the same?
In any case, I I feel bad but it's like, dude, I I do feel like
this is
like new age stuff. I feel like this is all the new age medicine
[__] The RFK type [__] that Jordan Peterson's
been into for a long time coming back and biting him and that
him and his his daughter are like both into the same stuff. To
me this was like more of the akathisia symptoms and rocking back
and forth to try to calm down or stamping my feet or like shaking
my hands. It felt like severe restless
but also in my arms and body. Everything I saw was pixelated.
I couldn't see color properly. I felt like I was in the upside
down in the show Stranger Things. I couldn't listen to music.
Music hurt my ears. There were days I couldn't watch TV even.
I couldn't lay in bed and watch TV. I just had to lay in a dark
room and try not panic. There wasn't a comfortable position I
could get into. Light hurt my eyes. Sound hurt my ears. My sense
of smell was heightened. I sprouted full-on allergies to things
I'd never been allergic to. At the time I was so unaware that
stopping Lexapro could cause these symptoms that I thought it
was my autoimmune disorder somehow or sudden extreme food sensitivities
because I had limited my Talking about benzos? No, nobody's talking
about benzos right now. Stop talking about benzos in the chat.
She's talking about how she went she was trying to get off of
her Lexapro and she went off of it quickly and she's having like
withdrawal symptoms from her Lexapro when she was younger.
Or she's possibly talking about after her first kid. She She's
like gone between them. She's trying to compare the akathisia
symptoms she had. I think when she went off of Lexapro versus
when she impending doom she felt when they thought her kid was
going to die. The two differences. I had to a paleo keto diet
which obviously >> doesn't make any sense. You don't cut
things out and then when you reintroduce them you hallucinate.
Like that's not a thing that happens. The main thing that flared
up my neurological injury were foods and preservatives in foods.
Um and then for dad symptoms when when they got really bad years
ago and more recently were more severe than We're not on an all
meat diet for fun. We're We're on an all meat diet because we've
been left with extremely long-lasting sensitivities and neurological
[clears throat] injuries from these medications and dad
I think the odds so the
Like trying to think through maybe there's some idea of
they both have a genetic proclivity for the same reaction to
antidepressants in some way, let's Right? Perhaps?
But it I uh man
this story to me feels very very psychosomatic. I I can't not
see it. I feel so bad for I feel bad for just not
Cuz it's like I dude, I I try to give people like the a chance
and to me it just it smacks of like psycho psychosomatic stuff.
I don't know but >> Dad's more sensitive than me. Maybe
he's older or on has SSRIs longer and because [__]
because of the clonazepam for sure. So that's a brief description
of my experience with akathisia and psych med withdrawal. It
lasted 2 and 1/2 years for me and it only started to go away
when I switched from a the paleo I don't feel like they deserve
it. I don't want to feel like they deserve it actually. I don't.
I actually would like to feel the opposite. And I By the way,
even if it's self uh self-induced, I don't think they deserve
it.
I do wish that they wouldn't
like advertise the sort of medical stuff that they do but I don't
think they deserve it even if it is self-inflicted.
I I'm saying that for them to I don't think they're going to
get better on their own. That's my real concern is I think they're
going to get worse and worse and worse
if they're left to their own devices. If Jordan Peterson's like
I don't I don't think this guy is getting better with his family
taking care of him. dairy-free keto diet to only eating
So in the middle of that antidepressant withdrawal years ago
now after a period of not sleeping from a reaction to a preservative
called sodium metabisulfite, dad was prescribed clonazepam and
most of you guys know this. He didn't take it for fun. He took
it because he hadn't slept in like 3 weeks. And I know that's
true because I had a similar We both ate the same thing that
had sodium meta Oh, I've heard that story from Jordan Peterson
before how he almost died. How like he he basically almost died
from a lack of sleep and he just needed something to get to sleep.
bisulfite in it and I had a similar response but very horrifying,
less severe though, where I threw up and then I didn't sleep
well for about 3 weeks and I was it was horrible, you know, horrible.
Um
he was pale near anaphylaxis, couldn't really breathe. That That
was one of those weird allergies that popped up that neither
of us had before stopping medication. I didn't have food allergies
before stopping those meds. Neither did Uh insomnia so severe
you do not sleep can be part of having a psych med induced neurological
injury. Glutamate skyrockets when GABA systems are damaged cuz
GABA is what counteracts glutamate and we don't really understand
a lot of what's happening but severe insomnia is discussed a
lot amongst people with psych med injuries. I had a hard time
sleeping for years even after my antidepressant withdrawal neurological
injury went away with the lion diet. I still have a hard time
sleeping. Like that's still my probably most sensitive area although
it's manageable. I'm like I'm fine. Uh but I use white noise,
a cold room, an eye mask, ear plugs. Something's still off. And
I'm sure it's from the lingering damage SSRIs did. Dad's doctor
prescribed him clonazepam for insomnia due to the undiagnosed
SSRI withdrawal or more aptly described as neurological injury
injured him further. And that's how he ended up with full-blown
akathisia for about 2 years after realizing the clonazepam was
causing issues after his doctor raised the dose of clonazepam.
When my mom was diagnosed with cancer and given 8 months to live.
All this stuff sounds crazy, dramatic but over the last 6 years
I've talked to hundreds and read a thousands of stories of people
who experienced injuries from psych medications that sound like
that. And these aren't out of the ordinary for those people.
Uh I wouldn't go into all this detail except I really do want
you guys to understand that as horrible as this is, what's worse
is this isn't
People who get injured by these don't have a a voice really.
They're too sick to have a voice but I've talked to and been
sent stories from thousands of people that are stuck in this
hell. SSRI prescriptions
SSRI prescriptions and benzodiazepine prescriptions long-term
are super common and the majority of people who take them especially
long-term have withdrawal or neurological injury from them. It's
almost always misdiagnosed as recurrence of their symptoms because
doctors will use the same words to describe it. And then these
poor people end up on two or three more medications to stabilize
their worsening mental illness when it's really neurological
damage from the medications
Most psychiatrists are completely unequipped to handle this.
They don't even know about this. They certainly
Man, it's like I don't doubt that there could be like rare complications
to drugs that aren't fully understood that could be the cause
of like one of their
I do find it quite difficult to stomach the idea that they both
have the same very very rare complication from two totally different
compounds.
That it was both like temporarily solved by a carnivore diet.
That sounds almost impossible to me.
Like that that does sound impossible. Like maybe one of them
but both of them? That feels
That feels like you've got to look at that and just go, "Okay,
I I need a second opinion." But I'm guessing they've got second
opinions for people who they they trust and those people are
probably not very trustworthy. >> talked about medical
school. Most people don't know it exists. Um when it happens
in families like a lot of the time these people are outcasts
because people can't understand why they're acting the way they're
acting. Uh and I'll be the first to say when I first took a Celexa
um it felt
like it worked. I felt my shoulders drop. I felt like I could
breathe again deeply. I stopped panicking. I stopped having thoughts
and my OCD disappeared.
That was when I was 11 but I remember it vividly. Um and I remember
how I felt like before I started taking them. But by the time
I was 13 I was certainly still depressed. I stayed on them because
I thought, "Oh my gosh, if this is how I feel with medication,
imagine how bad it is without it." But what ended up happening
as I got more and more mentally ill over the years was diagnosed
with bipolar type 2, had a seizure from Wellbutrin when that
was added in, suffered from severe restless legs that was really
intolerable that I thought was part of having an autoimmune disorder
or something. I didn't know what or
How should I put this? I do think
there is a propensity. I don't I don't also don't doubt that
there's a propensity to over-diagnose,
especially in the psychiatry field, illnesses that like require
lifelong medication that that lifelong medication I've seen personally
um with family
is not like I I think I've talked about how like my experience
is my grandma who had bipolar.
I could just like that is a struggle that I understand nobody
wants to There's a reason that nobody wants to take lithium,
okay?
There's a reason.
And I understand that people are like, "Yeah, well, listen, it's
going to be crazy without it." Dude, it's
That's just That's just crazy, okay?
Anyway, the the psychiatry stuff I I understand that like maybe
stuff's over-diagnosed, over-prescribed.
But uh and I don't know if that ties in. I feel like that I do
believe. That I feel like I've experienced with and I can believe
it.
Yeah, yeah, I know lithium is very different. I'm saying I know,
but she just said she was diagnosed bipolar type two, so that's
what I'm saying about that. Different thing, okay? I'm just saying
that a lot of this is like,
maybe don't talk to a psychiatrist." Also, I was going to say
I think that a lot of stuff like this Actually, it was probably
always going to be this
But I think it's the lack of routine a lot of people have. I
think if you lived like if you lived on a farm, you never got
a chance to be in your head enough to be like bi- bipolar in
some ways. You you did, and it came out, but I'm saying that
like you had such a routine and you had such discipline in sticking
to a routine that it had a hard time affecting your life in the
same way. I think it's like the it's a symptoms it's a symptom
of like how far we've come as a species almost in the first world
that like you could just you could consistently spiral in these
bad mental states.
Yeah. So, I I think there's like something to routine helping
a lot of people with these illnesses as well. It doesn't even
matter what the routine is, but if you're like very disciplined
in something, I think that tends to help a lot. That's why I
think things like diets probably help someone like Michaela because
if she's on a diet, she's doing something systematic.
It's like taking more and more time away
to like basically she's getting less time to just be in her head.
She's like focused on something else. associated with SSRIs.
And I just ended up getting worse and worse and worse.
I just always thought I would be even worse without the medications.
That wasn't true. Oh, I know there's a genetic component to bipolar,
okay? Very aware of that, yes. >> What I needed to focus
on was mitochondrial health, really. So, I'm going to get into
that now.
mitochondrial dysfunction is like ketogenic research. In 5 years,
it's going to be mainstream. Like ketogenic therapies are moving
into the mainstream, thank goodness. There's mounting evidence
that dementia, Parkinson's, Alzheimer's, long COVID, and those
weird chronic diseases that people get that are hard to treat
and kind of fringe, but most definitely exist, like chronic fatigue,
Lyme, POTS, MCAS, like those kind of things um that have this
large array of seemingly unrelated symptoms that include things
like chronic fatigue, depression, brain fog, anxiety, chronic
pain, lightheadedness, weird chemical and food sensitivities
are due to mitochondrial dysfunction. Because that impacts your
whole body and your brain. 10% of us by weight are mitochondria.
So, when I talk about neurological injuries, what I'm talking
about is mitochondrial dysfunction that manifests like a neurological
injury. This is pretty cutting-edge research, and I've linked
papers below so people can read more about it. In the previous
kind of announcement videos, I talked about how whatever was
going on with Dad had been diagnosed as CIRS. That's still true.
He definitely has CIRS. Um otherwise the mold exposures he experienced
wouldn't have caused neurological symptoms. It's chronic inflammatory
response syndrome, and it's almost like mold-induced illness.
Um I think that the genetic predisposition to mold illness is
likely what caused the severe mental illness that ran in my family
that was then treated with
Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm. Hm.
I Maybe I Man, I'm trying to be as charitable as
Did she figure out why her top lip doesn't move? That's intentional,
packed the man. That's That's intentional. That's a part of the
package. We She bought into that. That was something she signed
up for, okay? Voluntarily. >> about how Oh, I was going
to say the There probably is something with a genetic a genetic
predisposition to infla- inflammat- uh inflammatory diseases
like inflammation dumb. That That like if she had to have joints
replaced when she was a kid,
she obviously there's obviously some autoimmune condition that
runs in their family there that is causing problems,
But I don't know like mold, I guess that's their explanation.
I I really don't know. It's hard to say. mold illness is likely
what caused the severe mental illness that ran in my family that
was then treated with medication.
I talked about how it felt spiritual. And it does. It's been
hellish. Um I know like other people going through really stressful
periods with sick families like know what those periods of time
are like and like
it's hellish. My daughter last summer was hospitalized the same
day as my dad.
That seems odd. Oh. There there Frugals, thank you for the 23
months. Appreciated, man. a biological basis for what's going
on with Dad, and we finally know what it is. But I do think there
was a spiritual element or is. I'd also say if mentally ill desperate
people are given medication that's supposed to ease their suffering
that ends up nearly killing them when they stop or even while
they're on it and then they can't stop, I would say that's evil.
Have you guys heard of post-SSRI
It's way more common than people realize, too. And podcasters
are starting to talk about it, which is good, but it causes seemingly
permanent genital numbness and anhedonia, so emotional numbness.
It makes Does it? I Man, I
Dude, I I'm sorry. It's It's just everything hits me as like
this just-so story. And it's pretty weird now because I think
she's basically saying she's telling me so much about herself
and her life, and I feel like that's just another thing where
I'm like, "You're explaining some lack of attraction, some lack
of wanting to have sex with your You're like turning it into
some kind of
You're turning into some kind of like illness so that you don't
have to take it on. So, you don't have to take on any of the
problems that come along with not being attracted to your partner.
Or not having good sex with your partner. That's like what's
happening here. That feels like what's happening here to me.
Did your bias just show? I Okay.
Bro, SHE'S GOT A MILLION DIFFERENT incredibly rare complications,
and I don't know if you've ever dated a woman with 100 different
food sensitivities, but sometimes it's difficult to believe that
it's not psychosomatic, okay? There's only so many times I can
be like, "Yeah, they must have put garlic in that food cuz you're
really bloated right now." When you look the exact same, there's
only so many times I can have that conversation, okay? There's
only so many [__] times. And then I'm done. makes
people because they can't feel anything. Finasteride is one of
them. SSRIs. Um any medication that can cause things like that,
akathisia, PSSD, that level of suffering is evil. I think. I
do think our family has been attacked spiritually because I cannot
understand the level of suffering that I've been through a little
and my dad's been through and my whole family without it making
more sense through a spiritual lens. No, thank God I'm a Christian.
Anyway, away from the spiritual part. Um
So, this is the association between CIRS, chronic inflammatory
response syndrome, or basically mold-induced illness, ketogenic
diets, like the carnivore diet, and psych-med-induced neurological
injury. How do they connect together? Mitochondria. Mold causes
mitochondria to hibernate to protect themselves and shut down,
which causes this weird array of symptoms I talked about. Psych
meds cause mitochondrial dysfunction. I've linked the papers
that manifests as a neurological injury, and a ketogenic diet
gives mitochondria an alternate fuel that helps them heal and
helps them work, which is why it's so massively useful and why
we're just eating meat.
I'm going to put this video out, and people are going to tell
me I'm reaching, but this is now well-established research. Mitochondrial
dysfunction research is blowing up right >> Okay. I'm going
to talk about it more on my podcast because it's I promising.
It's really promising. I Like maybe. I understand that medicine
doesn't keep up like the cutting edge of medicine doesn't get
like prolific in mainstream for a while. Maybe. I guess I I'd
literally have to read the papers she's linking, right? What
is what do you mean saying? I pray for your father, but I'm a
pharmacist, so I don't want to screw him up any
Damn. And understanding what's wrong is really empowering. >> but
Um like I said, there are papers linked below, so you don't have
to just take my word for it. And I would've made this video shorter,
but I wanted to address everything I could. In a fit of frustration
and anger at the situation and how unfair it is, I put a website
together that I linked below called prescribed-harm.com,
which goes into the research about psychiatric medications and
what they're doing to people. And if you're watching this video
and have been injured by these medications, you can write your
story on that website, too, and I'll post it. Um or maybe that
website will be useful to explain to family members what's going
on. Or doctors who don't usually [clears throat] know what's
going on. Or leave a comment below to Yeah, I'm sorry.
It's like as soon as you do this whole story as well, and now
you're like, "Well, also, I'm going to start a website about
how the medical industry is like set up to harm you."
I This is the the the the the the the the the These are people
this isn't uncommon. These injured people assign ulterior motives
when it is much simpler than that. Brandy, give me the simplest
explanation for this. People are so hurt, like I said, that they
can't usually have their story told cuz they're just trying to
survive. And they're basically Is the simplest explanation that
she's just right about everything she's saying? She's going to
try to make money off of it. Oh, we're saying the same thing,
then. We're saying the same thing. Yeah, okay. >> and traumatized
and gaslit and
I'm going to be jumping up and down probably until this is dealt
with properly um about the dangers these medications produce
until things are changed or at least until it's common knowledge
that people need to be aware of this before they start the medication.
Pharmaceutical companies rename these neurological injuries and
psych-med side effects and use language to hide the symptoms.
Like there's malevolence here, too. Like calling akathisia restlessness
may cause restlessness. Calling akathisia
makes me want to hurt people. And maybe that's pregnancy hormones
talking, but it's criminal, really. There are no long-term studies
on these medications, yet most people take them for more than
5 years and are told that they're safe. Or at least safer than
their original mental issue. Actually, there's one long-term
study, and you know what it shows? That 60% of people have a
recurrence of symptoms. That's what they That's what they got
from the study. And need to go back on the medication. You know
what's stupid about that? They don't differentiate between recurrence
and withdrawal. And withdrawal is almost always misdiagnosed
as recurrence, even though the array of symptoms with withdrawal
is generally way more severe and includes pain syndromes and
sensitivities and new
They're just like, "Well, you just got worse." Nope. The industry
is so crooked. It's a travesty that now that there's actual solid
research linking ketogenic diets to improving mental disorders,
treating them, giving the brain the energy that it needs to not
be sick. I linked metabolicminds.com below, which is a great
site about ketogenic diets and mental illnesses, uh run by scientists,
and that diet or the carnivore diet should be first-line treatment
for mental illness, given they work and actually treat the energy
deficiency um that's causing mental illness, but especially because
these psych medications cause mitochondrial dysfunction long-term
that manifests as neurological injury and is very difficult if
not impossible to treat without time and life I'm just going
to say, I know like two people who have done this carnivore diet
And both of them suffer from your
Very, very rare symptoms. I know two people who've done that
diet long-term, and they both suffer these same symptoms. I'm
sorry, LIKE THAT IS me just painting by numbers. That is the
simplest explanation to me is that we've we've I see what's going
on here. lifestyle interventions like ketogenic diet, sun, sleep,
no stress, like seriously. Carnivore diet and a ketogenic diet
are different, too. That's the other thing that's very weird
here. stress
So, to end this rant, and apologies, I can see it's been 33 minutes,
um but I really did want to cover
everything, cuz it it's a lot. So, prayers are much appreciated
still.
And all this suffering we hope leads to more awareness so other
people can avoid this. Withdrawal is a silly name for what happens
to people, because we That's actually not true, ADHD runs me.
You you can't if you are not getting any fat, you something else
happens. There's a different thing that happens. You are It's
basically impossible to eat a meat-only diet and not enter ketosis,
but it is possible.
Like depending on how lean you're trying to get um with some
of the meat, it is
I don't think you're guaranteed to hit the the required fat levels.
It's just basically impossible if you're eating anything that's
like palatable.
But if you if you weren't doing anything, you would be
I don't know. Your brain needs carbs to function? Uh
Meat is protein and fat. Yes, meat is protein and fat. No, I
am saying that if you are eating certain types of lean
um I know this for a fact cuz I use have access to a lot of wild
meat, okay? And if you're eating like elk or moose, you're not
really getting any fat on that [__] Yeah, if they're
if they're going to the grocery store to stay on the on the carnivore
diet, ADHD runs me, they're going to they're going to end up
in ketosis, 100%.
And most people eat like cheese and stuff, too.
I just yeah, the all-meat stuff is just very silly, very, very,
very silly. Not enough fat, you could die on a pure protein diet.
Yeah, I know. I know. I know. I know.
You know, going mainstream is [__] up. I think keto
diets are fine. Like I don't think they have severe like short-term
effects. I think the reason the keto diets catch on is because
you end up losing like 10 lb of water weight, like really fast,
right? And so everybody thinks it works because the scale gets
like better really, really quickly, like within two or three
weeks you lose like 10 lb of water weight you didn't even realize
you had. And then
you basically you I it still works good after that, but people
lose water weight really, really, really fast on those.
I don't want to promise another update. I'm grumpy and pregnant,
and I don't want to be on the hook publicly for another update.
I don't want to talk about it. I'm going to talk about mitochondrial
dysfunction and psych med this travesty of psych med
I've been barely surviving with the pregnancy hormones and stress.
Thank goodness for my husband, who's just a rock, but I'm not
sleeping well. I wasn't eating well. Um at least this week it
appears I'm not crying constantly. Being in the second trimester
probably helps that, but that's it for updates about dad until
he's back. Now that we know it's a neurological injury, and we
know we need time for him to recover, and we can speed it up
by not provoking a reaction. Um like I said, prayers will
prayers are much appreciated um for my dad and for my brother,
my mom, and me, um and all the people helping us to help him
through this. So, there's light at the end of the tunnel, but
people need to know these medications and what they can do to
people, especially long-term, but not just long-term, and they
need to be aware of these before taking a medication. So, check
out everything I've linked below if you want. I spent some like
a decent amount of time trying to find good articles, and my
recent study that I posted that's being done on the carnivore
versus keto versus standard American diet and rheumatoid arthritis
and IBD, run by a research team, is linked below, and prescribed-harm.com
for more information on how to safely taper to avoid neurological
injury, and to read other people's experiences.
Do we think that she
when I look at the quote tweets and
do we think she's going to be getting
mocked more or supported more in the in the quotes? Uh this is
this is going to be sort of how I feel about it. I don't believe
a word of this. Something happened that puts him in a bad light.
This is just cover for it. I that's I honestly lean towards the
addiction stuff, but it is what it is. Has he not considered
not providing coverage for demons? Okay. All right, these people
are mean. These people are
What the hell, man? What the heck?
Give him hell. [__] Okay, stop.
Stop. Stop. Stop. I did I'm done with the video in any case.
Let's check out some of the quotes.
Peterson's fall is tragic in every sense of the word. He appeared
on the scene uh da da da da da da Pray for him.
Pray for him.
Why we don't have free health care. They're a family of psychos
that blame everything wrong in their lives on made-up undiagnosable
medical conditions, like a psychotic teenage girl trying to get
out of PE because their fibromyalgia is acting up. I hate them
so much.
Anti-pharmaceutical arc, let's go. This serves, hey, let's. Anyone
mocking Mikhaila Mikhaila is clearly a bot because what human
would mock such a
I mean, realistically, I just like to know that somebody could
have a reaction, and I don't believe that she would have a reaction
to anything I said to her.
come on, man. That's even worse.
That's even worse. What the hell, dude? Not reading all that.
PS, totally would. Puff. Dude, come on, man. Come on. Come on,
man.
These people are animals, dude. These people on Twitter are animals.